what's up guys so as you guys already
know coffee lake has been out for a
couple of months now and even the
overpriced CPUs like the intel i7 8700 k
have returned to MSRP however there's
still one major flaw with coffee lake
you will have to get a z 370 motherboard
if you want to use your new cpu and this
doesn't make any sense if you were
considering buying the i3 or even if you
just didn't want the extra features that
the z3 70 comes with and just prefer to
save money with the motherboard in a
cheaper range with the cheapest z3 70
motherboard coming at us and at $100 it
makes no sense to buy the i3 8100 begins
with this combo the CPU itself is only
eighteen dollars more than the
motherboard the new budget chipsets were
supposed to fill this void and make this
a much more reasonable purchase the h3
10 H 370 and beet 360 we're slated to be
released in the first quarter of 2018
but since then there hasn't been much
news about these budgets chipsets so
where are they
well here's the good news there are some
signs that these new chipsets are coming
out very soon some retailers have leaked
us pricing for the new coffee-like CPUs
that were promised by Intel to the come
alongside the new chipsets these new
CPUs include the i5 8600 which is
supposed to have six cores six threads
and a base clock of 3.1 gigahertz and it
comes in at 208 dollars next the i5
8,500 which also has six cores of six
threads but its base speed is three
gigahertz and it comes in at 189 dollars
and then there's the i3 8300 which is
supposed to have four cores and four
threads at 3.7 Gate Hertz and comes in
at 135 dollars before we move any
further I want to tell you that I have
no idea why they're coming out with
these new chips because they are very
redundant for example why would you buy
two 8300
it's $25 more than the 80 100 and here's
what it brings extra a whole point 1
gigahertz it's actually stupid and same
thing with the 8680 500 dare
differentiated with about $20 in price
but speed difference is only 100
megahertz so guys don't buy these CPUs
unless there's a crazy deal on them and
then there's also a few Pentium and
Celeron CPUs coming out as well and same
thing here I don't know why you would
spend an extra $10 on a g4 290 for an
extra 100 megahertz as opposed to the g4
900 anyways what did these new CPU show
us well if there is more budget oriented
CPUs coming out then I think we can
safely assume that the budgets chipsets
are just around the corner as well so
should you buy these CPUs well that
depends mainly on your budget and what
CPU you are buying if you're considering
to buy the I 580 600 K or the i7 8700 K
then I strongly recommend and you guys
get a Z 370 motherboard because you're
just wasting the full potential of your
CPU if you don't instead you could have
got just gotten a 8700 for less money
and almost the same performance however
if you're considering the other AI 5s or
i3 / Celeron or pentium then yes I do
recommend that you guys go with the
budget motherboard because there's
really no point in getting a Z 370 board
for those kinds of chips but they don't
really help with performance if you can
afford a more expensive motherboard then
why don't you just get a better chip I
know there will be some of you guys who
are like I'm gonna get the 8i 383 50k
with a Z 370 motherboard right now so
that later always upgrade my CPU instead
what you should do is get the I to me
8350 with the cheap $50 motherboard
right now and get the I to 790 700 K or
9600 K when they come out with their
respective motherboards please just
don't make really polar combinations it
doesn't make any sense
finally on my last video one of my
subscribers asked me if they should get
coffee lake in May or if they should
just wait for next generation
and the simple ash to that is if you're
looking at getting an i3 or lowered then
you should just go ahead and buy it now
this next generation is unlikely to
really add much performance in those
chips however if you're looking at the
8700 K then you should consider waiting
for the 9700 K because that may have
eight cores and that would be worth the
wait
well guys over all the new chipsets
should be coming up very soon as an
March or April even so what do you guys
think about these new chipsets like do
you think they are overdue at this point
and what do you think about the new CPUs
do you think that they are redundant
make sure to post what you guys thinking
and comments down below I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think well guys that's what I have
for you guys this time if you liked this
video make sure to drop a like and smash
that subscribe button if you want to see
more videos just like this and hit that
Bell notification if you want to be
notified every time I post in your video
but until next time bye
[Music]